をおおおおおお！
きゃああああああああ！！
あれ？ここ集合場所うなのに、おかしいな〜
こんにちは
こ・・・こんにちはwwww
奇跡に取材を受け入れてくれた
かぼちゃ人間である
何年ぶりですか？
一年ぶりすね
今人間界のあれでしょ？
ハロウィーンでしょ？
はい
やっばハロウィーンの季節に我々野菜は
まあ、人間ぽい形になり
ここに帰ってくると
いろいろ人間界を教えてくれるすよね
はい、任せてください
いや、一年ぶりに来てるけど
あっまり変わらんなこの世界は
ここはどこなんだよ
ここは・・・海ですね
野菜初めてですか見るのは？
あっまりこっちの世界じゃないすけど
いつも土ですよね
お！
見ろ！
これが人間のありさまだ
人間だちはいつもポイ捨てをしているのか
いや、そんな事はない
をおおおおお！！！わああああ！！！
去年、緑色の友達いたじゃないですか
うれれっれえれれれっれ！あ、んん
こ・・・今年はいないんですか？
は！
いるよ、あ！
今年も連れて来てる
お！
紹介してくださいよ
ちょと電車乗り遅れてwwwww
もうちょと届くから、たぶん
なるほど、電車に輸送すると
はああああ！
きょうの番組では
ハロウィーンの日しか現れないかぼちゃ人間の一日を密着取材してみようと思う
（滑った・・・）www
見よう、この木色
環境枠に負けず
しっかりと根ばいっているだろ
まあ、こうゆう野菜だちをちゃんと
平和に、幸せに出来る世界を築きたいと思ってる
素晴らしいですね
お友達はまだ来ないで・・・
あああああお！
二年前ぐらいから、この能力を身に付・・うう！
いて
それから・・・うふうふう！
それからこの能力を使いにな・・・ふう！た
そろそろ友達来ましたね
もうすぐ来ると思うよ・・・ううは！
これがこの世界の水か
（滑った）あああ！
ここら辺にいるって情報・・・わあへえはあひい！手に入れたから
たぶんもうすぐいる・・うふうう！
いるぞたぶん
いたぞ！
去年の友達スイカ君だ
二人は出会うと同時に
寂し気に
人間界の海を眺めていた
二人も去年こちの世界に来たら
まだ言葉が喋れない
今回新しく
仲良し
そして
パリピwwww
この二つと
パリピ
これ覚えた
パチパチパチパチ
プふ！
はふはふはふはふはふは！はふはっふ
はふは〜はたいしんせいやく！はふは〜
人間よ
なんでしょ
人間どもが冷たい目でこっちを見てくる
辞めろ！！
ぱひ！ぱりぱり！ぱぱ！
辞めてよ！
今日確かもう一人ぐらいくる予定だったんだけどな
電車ですかね
ああ！！
そこにわ
野菜人間に対する
人間たちの脅迫な現実が待ちかまえでいた
おい！
止めにいくぞ！
やめろ！
うわ！うわあああ！
大丈夫か？
こいつは
今日
初めて人間界にきた
ブドウだ
ブドウ野菜じゃねじゃんかよ
うええ！えええええええ！
彼ら野菜人間わいつになったら
人間たちになじめるのだろか
そんな未来を描き
彼らは
人間界を満喫していた
いや〜
なんか前と変わらず
まあ、思ったより平和だったんで
いや・・ひひ！
よかたと思います
うわ！！！
ちょとちょとなにやているんですか！
やめでくださいよ
やめてくださいってば！！
ああ！